markets appear to be banking on a soft
landing for the u.s economy are you
starting to think that a soft landing is
a real possibility soft landing yes no a
soft landing means lower inflation a
minimal increase in unemployment and
economic growth for the rest of the year
you're seeing these expectations in
stocks bonds and even in crypto but
there's one market where these
expectations could really unravel that
soft landing thesis
currencies
i'm going to show you what we're seeing
in markets explain the role the dollar
has played and break down why a weaker
dollar could reverse a lot of the good
news we're seeing
let's get into it markets have been
rallying since mid-june and got a big
boost from july's consumer price index
report that showed lower than expected
u.s inflation
tech stocks and meme stocks have boomed
along with junk bonds and
cryptocurrencies those are all signals
that investors are bullish and look to
be pricing in a stronger economy these
bullish expectations have also caused a
notable decline in the value of the u.s
dollar which rose to a 20-year high in
june the dollar rose as currency traders
priced an aggressive action from the
federal reserve and other central banks
that looked like it could cause a global
recession a weak global economy benefits
the dollar because it's the world's
reserve currency and it's sought during
times of instability but with
inflation's decline along with falling
gas prices and rising consumer sentiment
traders are reversing those bets the fed
is now expected to raise interest rates
by less this year and to begin cutting
rates next year even though fed
policymakers have said that is not their
plan what we need to see is inflation
coming down
in a clear and convincing way
and we're going to keep pushing until we
see that it's worth watching the
currency market because the strong
dollar has helped keep u.s inflation
from jolting even higher a stronger
currency means imports cost less and the
u.s has been importing a record amount
of goods since the pandemic in fact the
growing u.s trade deficit was a big part
of the negative gdp growth we've seen in
the first two quarters this year u.s
companies made more complaints about the
strong dollar hurting their earnings
during the second quarter than they have
at any time since 2015. a weaker dollar
would put upward pressure on the prices
americans are paying and could also
increase the price of commodities like
oil wheat and copper that could be good
for the stock market but bad for the
overall economy because a weaker dollar
means rising prices which of course
means rising inflation and the decline
in inflation is at the center of the
soft landing expectations we're seeing i
made a video about how the dollar
impacts prices in the economy back in
january check that out if you want to
learn more even if inflation doesn't
rise meaningfully if it holds above
eight percent where it's been since
march that could cause some headaches
that markets don't seem to be pricing in
watch the markets like detroit rapper
big sean who says success is my idol
being broke is my rival but it's cool
because i've got the title
that's all for now i'll see you next
time